[rock music]
- This is my forge.
My own tools.
I know what I have.
I may not quite know where
it's at, but I know it's here.
We have a little mini mill
for sanding.
I hate changing drill bits,
so I have several drills.
And we have this anvil here
in the--in the front.
This anvil belonged
to my grandfather.
We have a 50-pound
mechanical power hammer.
My first hammer that I--
that I ever owned.
And then we have a band saw
for cutting the bar stock.
And one of the things that's
kind of important in this shop
is I have my little
pallet jack.
I can move most of
my heavier machines around
to whatever configuration is
most comfortable at the time.
♪ ♪
- Welcome to Clinton,
Mississippi.
Let me show you my shop.
This was the first 2x72 grinder
I built
from an old office desk.
This is a little nicer 2x72.
It's got variable speed control
and several different
tooling arms.
This is a fly press.
This allows me to do
a lot of controlled forging.
And this is a really, really
old tool--
probably a good--
close to 200 years old.
My number one pride
and joy in the shop right now
obviously is the self-contained
air hammer.
This takes my forging
from the anvil
and turns it into
a much easier task.
♪ ♪
- 30 years ago,
I quit my real job,
started blacksmithing
full time.
I've been making fire screens,
fire tools, railings.
Here was have a railing
I was commissioned to do.
And making all the vines,
they're all forge welded.
Each one of these is
an individual piece,
welded to each other,
and then a short piece
welded,
and another vine
welded on there.
And when it got all done,
it looks awesome.
- I made both of these forges.
This is just a small
one-burner forge,
and I'll do the majority
of my forging in this guy,
and then when I need to heat
something
that's a little bit longer,
I'll use this--this big forge
right here.
This is a inline treadle
hammer.
This allows me to do things
where I would need a striker
or might need some help.
I can actually put work
in here
and do things with two hands,
rather than having to
juggle with one.
A welder and then
an old washing machine motor
that's been turned into
a grinding station.
I've had the buffer
throw my knife before
but it never got me.
So that's my shop.